welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the
trailer for Wonder Woman 1984 dropping
last week and confirming that Steve
Trevor was going to be alive for the
movie it's time to break down some of
the best fan theories and predictions
for how the character is going to return
if we're right here there will be heavy
spoilers so if you don't want the film
potentially ruined then I highly suggest
that you turn off now I'm also gonna be
going over some of the plot leaks from
the October screening to discuss what
they said and how the death of the
character is apparently reckoned you
should always take the leaks like this
with a pinch of salt but they were
released before the trailer and seemed
to line up with it a lot so yeah that
could also definitely be true anyway
I'll leave those until the end and
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of how
Steve Trevor is still alive
okay so cast your mind back to 2017 and
the first Wonder Woman movie set during
the first world war the film centered
around an American spy known as Steve
Trevor who had wittingly stumbled across
their mascara an island made up of
Amazonian women most notably Diana
Prince
aka Wonder Woman teaming up together the
two fought their way across the Western
Front in order to stop the use of a
highly toxic gas being used in the
conflict during the final battle a pair
discovered that there was a bomber
filled with the deadly gas that was
about to unleash the poison on several
key places and Steve ended up piloting
it to a safe altitude before detonating
the aircraft with himself onboard it was
a massively heroic moment that pretty
much changed the landscape of the war
but also left a huge hole in Diana's
life even a century later in the film
Justice League Dai is still clearly hung
up on the characters passing and due to
his popularity it looks like Warner
Brothers are to Chris Pine was just too
good to leave out of a sequel and this
clearly left the creative team at an
impasse as the character has been
resurrected
now comic books are full of time-travel
magic devices and no one ever really
stays dead but the first big theory that
is currently going about the net is that
this isn't really Steve Trevor some
people believe that it's actually
cheetah in disguise
okay so firstly
we haven't seen Kristen Wigg in full chi
to get up we know from the behind the
scenes information that she will be
playing the villain s in the trailer she
seems almost infatuated with Wonder
Woman and currently there exists a
theory that Steve is just cheater in
disguise in order to get close to Diana
cheater aka Barbara and Minerva
possesses shape-shifting abilities and
in the past the character has taken on
many different forms so this is an
outside the realm of possibility
from the first look at the film we see
the to discussing love and Diana says
that she's only ever been in love once
which as we know is Steve Trevor cheetah
knows this information firsthand now and
will likely conclude that it is Steve
that Diana's heart still pines for due
to the memorabilia that's scattered
about her apartment therefore in order
to get close to her it is possible that
she has taken on the appearance of Steve
and this is why we not only see her
cheetah form absent from the trailer but
also why the character is still alive
this could also explain why we see
Trevor in a he's clothes as cheetah
would want to blend in as much as
possible to the rest of the world and in
order to do this she would need to get
more fitting attire than a World War 1
uniform I'm not 100% sold on their spurt
out of a lot of the theories that I've
seen this one definitely sells itself
the best on to the next theory which
comes directly from comic-book comm who
even put out a big video theorizing that
the character could be a clone which
also isn't outside the realm of
possibility and similar to the prior
theory they stated that Steve has been
created in order to get close to Diana
who at this time is probably seen as the
world's only superhero
another theory that's making the rounds
at the moment is that Steve Rogers ended
up with a very similar fate to Steve
Trevor with some fans drawing the
similarities between the two looking at
it from a top-level view both sacrificed
themselves while it's piloting a bomber
during a world war that ended up tearing
them away from the love of their lives
both have similar sounding names and
some have even theorized that the toxins
on board the craft somehow changed Steve
in some ways giving him an almost super
soldier like physicality that has
allowed him to remain preserved for all
this time honestly I can't see Warner
Brothers going with this though as it's
just so close to what Marvel did and
personally out of all these theories
this is the worst one now finally onto
the plot leaks which
as I mentioned earlier in the video
apparently come from a screening of the
film in October and going off the
trailer they actually look like they
line up quite a lot we don't want the
movie ruined then now is your last
chance to turn off because from here on
out we're gonna be going over some major
plot elements that could spoil the film
for you okay so if you're still here
thanks for sticking around and
apparently the movie actually focuses on
Barbara a Minerva who's an archaeologist
that has been scouring the world for
rare artifacts on the payroll of her
benefactor Maxwell Lord this is why she
meets Diana early on because as we know
from BBS Wonder Woman and Justice League
Diana is an expert when it comes to rare
and historical items so it makes sense
that Barbara would confide in what is
probably the world's leading authority
apparently at the behest of Lord Barbara
is trying to track down a rare and
mystical stone that grants wishes and in
the trailer we do see at one point Lord
looking over this so it does seem like
it's indeed in the movie the stone
apparently grants wishes and allows the
person who holds it to have anything
that their heart desires unfortunately
though it has some monkey poor effect
and the wishes often come with a curse
to them that carries dire consequences
upon finding the stone Barbara wishes to
have superpowers which in turn over time
it transforms her into cheetah angry at
this she sets out on a quest to kill
Lord and left with no other option he
turns to Wonder Woman for protection the
stone also explains how Lord is able to
get so rich and basically become a
celebrity that's plastered across TV
screens everywhere diana is and always
will be a hero at heart and she is still
a protector of people even if they may
seem like they're in the wrong which was
a big motif of the graphic novel the
hickety air which had the Amazonian
princess going head-to-head with Batman
after he wanted to bring justice to a
woman that she had chosen to God anyway
scrubbing all that Diana or realising
that Lord has the power to grant wishes
strikes up a deal with the character
that becomes the reason that Steve
returns in exchange for her protection
Diana says that all she wants is Steve
back and Lord grants this wish which is
how the character is resurrected like we
said earlier this kind of has a monkey
poor affect and he ends up inhabiting
the body of someone else and thus they
lose their life in some way so that's
the
can live however the to do work together
throughout the movie in order to stop
cheater from completing her endgame
apparently diana is also the only person
that can see steve but it doesn't matter
to her as he's all she cares about
anyway I don't want to spoil all of the
movie but I have done a portly breakdown
on that if you want to check it out that
is apparently how Steve's able to return
from the dead and to me going off the
trailer it makes a lot of sense
personally though I am still a bit
unsure of the entire thing and now I
know that comic books often bring
characters back from the dead
I do feel like Steve should have
remained that way his sacrifice at the
end of the first movie was a really bold
one and we already know from BBS which
revolved around Diana tried to get a
photo of her and the world war 1 squad
back that the character doesn't survive
the events of this movie knowing Steve
is dead either way kind of strips the
entire point of this resurrection but at
least it may grant the character the
ability to say the goodbye that she
never really got to I also think that
having Steve returned for this film also
makes it so that you sort of have to
have him return for a third film which
they'll inevitably make if this one is
successful if he doesn't come back for
that then it's kind of almost like a
hollow victory for Diana as you know
that she's still mourning the loss of
her love Steve it kind of paints them
into a corner and as mentioned earlier I
do think that Warner Bros regret killing
off the character as if the leaks are
true it's a pretty strange way to bring
him back
hopefully this movie is more wish
fulfillment than evil curse as I would
love to see it keep the DC train on
track after the success of films like
Shazam Joker and even Aquaman which I
did like even if it had that terrible
pitbull song in it either way I guess
we're gonna find out next year when the
film is released worldwide on the 5th of
June 2020 it's gonna gonna be weird
googling this film down the line though
and it's like Wonder Woman 1984 2020
anyway that's for the 45 year old
version of heavy spoilers to worry about
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the leaks and if you think
that they're real or if you have another
completely different theory comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our full
plot League breakdown of Star Wars the
rise of Skywalker would you be linked at
the end we go over the entire 4,000 word
plot leak and break down everything that
you need to know about the movies so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me after the video then
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey
or head over to my discord server which
you'll be linked in the description
below we drop videos on there early so
if you want to see stuff before anyone
else and that's the best place to be
it's free to join and we have an awesome
community so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the marble phase 3 potty
boxer on blu-ray which contains Black
Panther infinity war and Game Captain
Marvel er more and all you have to do to
be in with the chance of winning is like
the video maybe subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on how Steve
comes back to life in the comments
section below the winners gonna be
chosen the 15th of December and the set
will be shipped out from then to ever
gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition and you've been the best
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]